hi everyone my name is lima murshi i'm a
senior principal research manager at
microsoft research
and i'm here today with my colleague
mahela vorvaranu director of ux research
and responsible ai education at ether
ether is microsoft's advisory committee
on ethics in engineering and research
and we're here today to talk to you
about how you can create human-centered
ai with the human ai experiences toolkit
or the hacks toolkit for short
before i begin i just wanted to
acknowledge the many researchers and
practitioners and interns who have
contributed to the toolkit over the
years
the toolkit has really been a multi-year
collaboration between microsoft research
and ether
and it's about has been about
understanding challenges in building
responsible and human-centered ai and
developing solutions and tools to help
so in this tutorial we're going to first
give an overview of what human centered
ai is and why we need it
then we'll briefly introduce the hacks
toolkit which contains a suite of tools
that we've been developing to help ai
creators and teams build ai technologies
in a human-centered way
and then finally mahala will go through
each tool in a little more detail with a
case study of a team at microsoft who
has been using the toolkit for their own
ai driven product
okay so human centered ai what is it and
why do we need it
so first i'm going to start with some
context
so here you see a map of the 2020 data
and ai landscape which is published
every year by first mark venture capital
and it really just goes to show the
breadth and the reach of ai in our
everyday applications services and
industries
and while we know that ai and machine
learning are really powerful
technologies that have the potential to
enhance our capabilities and improve our
lives
as a ai extends into our every aspect of
our lives we're also starting to see
more and more evidence of its potential
to cause significant harm
right and so for this i'd say
pick your headlines
right on the left here we see computer
vision technology
which has been used to help blind and
low vision people sense who and where
people are in their environment this is
from microsoft's project tokyo
but on the right here we see we see very
similar technology
that has been used by law enforcement
officers in new york
who use an undisclosed facial
recognition system to find and harass a
black lives matter activist named derek
ingram that you see here
okay so it's this potential for harm
that is causing society to really start
to demand change and accountability
particularly for when ai is used in
critical and life-changing scenarios
and so the industry is really being
called upon to reflect and rethink how
we build our ai technologies to ensure
that we can do so in a responsible way
now there are many challenges to
creating ai responsibly
including cultural challenges around
shifting mindsets and embracing
diversity throughout product development
it also includes organizational
challenges such as aligning business
objectives with responsible ai
objectives
but today i'll be focusing on some of
the technical challenges
meaning tech challenges around how we
build ai technologies in a responsible
and so when i say technical here
what i won't be talking about actually
is algorithmic challenges or automated
solutions for building ai
and that's not because that's not
necessary
it's because we're really a long way
from purely technical solutions that can
automate all aspects of developing ai
technologies
and we may never even get here because
responsible ai still requires a lot of
human judgment and careful decision
making throughout the process of
building and deploying our ai
technologies
for example it can involve making
trade-offs between different values and
goals when deciding what to optimize
during model building
okay so instead today i'm going to focus
on how we can support the people
building our ai technologies so that
they can do so in a responsible way
so this is where human centeredness
comes in
that is building ai responsibly requires
that we adopt some human-centered
practices
okay so what's that um people use this
term in many different ways
i like to relate it back to its origins
and human-centered design
which says that it's about ensuring that
what we build benefits people in society
and that how we build it begins and ends
with people in mind
okay now you might be thinking well that
sounds really nice and warm and fuzzy
but how do we actually do this in
practice
now there are some general best
practices for building ai in a
human-centered way
this includes first thinking about
end users and thinking about them early
so that you can tie all technical
decisions about your ai model and system
back to users goals and needs
so what i mean by that
this is that human centeredness
prescribes doing that upfront research
and understanding of people and the
variety of contexts in which those
people may be using your ai system
and using that to make all the decisions
about the rest of the system
so for example
if your aia based technology is supposed
to work on a broad range of people
then the data you collect should really
be representative of all of those people
similarly if your ai technology is going
to
or the end users of your ai technology
are going to need an explanation
it's really important to choose a model
that can provide an explanation or
choose an interpretable model
now another best practice in
human-centered ai is that
if your ai isn't intended to work for a
broad range of people and scenarios
it's really important to involve diverse
perspectives throughout development
this includes talking to diverse sets of
potential users
but also involving diverse members of
your team especially when making
critical decisions about the system's
functionality and capabilities
human-centered ai also suggests that we
anticipate and plan for different types
of failures so that the people who are
ultimately going to be using your system
can
recover when things inevitably go wrong
okay so these are just some best
practices for human-centered ai
but it's easier said than done
and this is why we created the hacks
toolkit to help operationalize these
best practices
so the hacks toolkit which you see here
on the left and you can reach at the url
on the screen
is a set of tools for creating
responsible ai experiences
and so our goal here with the toolkit as
i said was to really operationalize some
of these human-centered best practices
in our everyday work
and we do this by creating tools for
really empowering
interdisciplinary teams working to build
ai
and that includes teams involving model
builders engineers designers user
researchers and pms
and each of the tools in the toolkit is
grounded in explicit needs that we've
discovered through our engagement with
product teams
and has been tested with real product
developers and engineering teams
and now these are research-based tools
and so we're continuously evolving them
as we learn
and work with teams to make sure that
they're they're usable
and effective
so in the rest of this talk i'm going to
be introducing you to some of the tools
in the toolkit which you can actually
start using right away if you go to this
website
so currently the toolkit includes these
tools that help with different parts of
the ai development process and more will
be coming soon as as we develop them
so the first tool is the guidelines for
human a interaction which is a set of
best practices for how ai systems should
behave during human interaction with an
ai product
second is a hacks workbook which is a
tool to guide teams through planning and
implementing human ai interaction best
practices
the hacks design patterns are a set of
flexible and reusable solutions to
recurring human ai interaction problems
so these are about how to implement
human ai interaction best practices
and then finally the hacks playbook is a
tool for generating scenarios to test
based on likely human ai interaction
failures
so i'm going to briefly go over each of
these
so first the guidelines for human eye
interaction
so the guidelines were actually released
back in 2019 and this was a
collaboration with people across
microsoft to synthesize and validate
best practices for designing human
interaction with an ai system
and we created the guidelines because
not only is ai extending into our
everyday lives and technologies
it's also really fundamentally changing
how we interact with those technologies
for example by enabling new methods of
interaction and new sensing capabilities
at the same time
ai is also creating new challenges for
people during interaction
and we see this in everything from
humorous ai failures like when our
conversational agents misunderstand us
like we see on the left here
to really dangerous situations like when
an ai is being used in high-stakes
scenarios
so on the right here we see a
semi-autonomous vehicle which missed a
fire truck that was stocked stopped on
the road
and in this case the driver wasn't able
to intervene and recover in time
okay so we created the guidelines to
help ai design and developers design for
safe and effective human interaction
with ai
now i won't go into details of how we
created these
other than we did four rounds of
synthesis and iteration and evaluation
of the guidelines with over 60 user
experience professionals
and tested against 20 ai real ai
products and so you can learn more about
this in the paper
but the point of this is just to say
that we didn't just make these up we
really endeavored to take a systematic
and rigorous research-based approach to
developing the guidelines so we
ourselves could feel confident in their
effectiveness
so here are the guidelines which you see
on screen there are 18 of them and
they're broken up into four categories
roughly based on when they would apply
as a user interacts with an ai system
okay now these are rough categories
they're not hard assignments um but we
categorize them this way just to make
them easier to remember
so the first category here initially
is really all about setting expectations
and expectations are important because
people often have unrealistic
expectations about ais
because of their complexity and how
they're portrayed in the media
but we know that unrealistic
expectations can not only lead to
frustrations and product abandonment it
can also lead to over-reliance and
under-reliance
during interaction which can be
detrimental depending on the scenario of
use
the next category is all about
context
and context is really important for ai
because ai systems typically make
inferences about people and their needs
and those needs depend on the user's
environment
including their current task and their
attention as well as a larger social and
cultural context in which they're
operating
so these guidelines describe
considerations for designing your ai
system to match those social and
cultural contexts in which people will
be using it
the third category is all about what to
do when the ai is inevitably wrong
and i can't stress this enough your ai
will be wrong and so if there's one
thing i want you to take away from this
tutorial is that your ai will be wrong
and so it is very important to include
mechanisms to reduce the cost to users
when this happens
and so these set of guidelines outline
how to do this for common ai failures
and errors
then the final category here is all
about what to do as the user interacts
with the system over time
and this again is important for ai
because
one of the key benefits of ai models
are their ability to learn and improve
over time
but this can also be disruptive if that
interaction is not designed carefully
okay
now i won't go into details of the
guidelines and you'll but you'll learn
about more of them throughout the rest
of this talk but teams have been using
them um throughout microsoft and
externally um and they say things like
the guidelines are you know really all
about how to create trustworthy
assistive systems
that have really been given a tremendous
authority over human life and we saw
that from the beginning as our ais are
extending into our everyday lives
another
person who's been using the guidelines
on their team said
it took us four years to come up with 80
of the guidelines if you can
institutionalize this into the design
parts of your products you really give
people an opportunity to build a much
better product in gen 1.
and that's really what this is for
now
while the guidelines are widely used
throughout our many workshops talks and
engagement with teams
we've continued to learn about
challenges that they're facing
including how to make the guidelines
part of people's everyday work
because while they describe best
practices there's still work to be done
to include it in our everyday work
processes
in addition the guidelines
are as one person said here are based
more a lot of them are based more upon
engineering than even design and some
would require full-scale overhaul of the
back end and so what that means is that
if the guidelines aren't planned for
early in development it's going to be
too late to try to introduce them at the
end okay so if the spec doesn't have the
guidelines built in it's going to be too
rigid to respond
so these and some of the other
challenges that we learned about
during our engagements inspired several
of the other tools in the toolkit
so for example the hacks workbook
is what you is what you see here it's a
simple and flexible excel worksheet to
help guide early planning conversations
around the guidelines
so the workbook is really intended to be
used when you
have an idea for a new user-facing
ai-based feature and you're starting to
sort of define your requirements
or if you have an existing user-facing
ai feature a prototype that you want to
evolve or improve
so this is what the workbook actually
looks like
we iteratively co-developed it with 43
pack practitioners over several sessions
to really define the right breakdown and
sequence of steps needed to plan for
the ai user experience early
and to accurately estimate resources
required to build them
okay so the workbook guides teams
through five separate steps
first is identifying guidelines that are
relevant
and this is because you know as i said
before there are 18 guidelines but not
all of them are going to be relevant for
every single product scenario so step
one is to figure out which ones are
relevant to your scenario
in step two you discuss the potential
impact of the guidelines on your end
users
in step three you define the
implementation requirements
and then you use both the the
understanding of the impact to users
along with the cost of implementation to
prioritize which ones your team should
implement
and then finally you can track the steps
the the guidelines that you've decided
to implement in the workbook here or in
your own product development tools
and so michaela will actually go over
this workbook in more detail
but i wanted to highlight that in step
three here where you talk about
different implementations
this is where you can bring into the
conversation the hacks design patterns
okay
so the design patterns we created
because
there are often many ways to implement
each of the guidelines
and so through our work with the
guidelines and with teams we've
collected hundreds of examples of of the
guidelines being applied in everyday
products
so what we did here was we work through
those examples that we've collected to
distill a set of patterns
that abstract away those sort of
application specific details
to describe flexible solutions to
recurring human ai experience problems
that people could apply new scenarios
so we currently have about 33 design
patterns for eight of the guidelines
that you see here
and we're continuing to develop more
and all of these patterns along with
examples from real ai products are
available in the hacks toolkit in our
hacks design library
so the design library is something that
you can filter through and browse to see
how the guidelines are being applied in
different product scenarios and to look
at the patterns to see which ones might
be
most effective for your product scenario
we've also made the design library
extensible so people and the community
can contribute new examples or patterns
as we learn and grow in how to design
effective human interaction with ai
now the final tool introduced today is
the hacks playbook and this was designed
for generating scenarios to test based
on likely human ai interaction failures
and we created this tool because
as we were working with product teams we
found that it was very hard for them to
anticipate the different ways an ai
may fail at any given moment
and that's because ai systems are
probabilistic they're designed to
generalize to new scenarios so it can be
hard to anticipate when and what will go
wrong at any given moment
and so what the playbook does is it
helps teams proactively and
systematically explore common ai failure
scenarios
so that they can go beyond the golden
path
and it's really what you see here on the
right is something where you can walk
through and answer a set of questions
about your product scenario and then the
system will generate different potential
failure scenarios that you can design
for and test
so each of these tools is available to
use now
at the at the url that you see on screen
and with that i'm going to hand things
over to my co-lead mahela who's going to
walk through using these tools in a real
case study from a team at microsoft
so thanks
all right so let's take a look at a case
study
seeing how
an actual feature in an app that has
been released by microsoft
used the hacks toolkit to improve the
user experience and make it a
responsible one
so we'll be talking about the microsoft
family safety app
this is part of modern life experiences
and this particular app is meant to
promote digital safety and well-being
in the sense that there's a family admin
who can set
limits for browsing for apps can filter
content and avoid surprise spending
the app has a feature called now flagged
search that flags potentially toxic
search terms
so that parents or guardians can discuss
these searches with their children
now
these are some early mock-ups of this
app
and you can see how initially it would
highlight um
search terms that were classified as
toxic or concerning
the modern life experiences team worked
with us proactively to mitigate
potential harms at microsoft we have a
process for apps that are or products
that are considered to potentially have
risks and harms to psychological harms
to undergo review and consulting and so
this is how we met the team
and we worked with them on this app as
you can imagine there could be several
for example psychological harms to
children
if they are embarrassed or if their
privacy is invaded through some searches
that they do
especially if you think about them
trying to discover their own identity
for example and so this was really a
sensitive topic and we were really
happy to have a chance to work with this
team um to mitigate some of these harms
so uh the team filled out the hacks
workbook over two or three sessions
where they worked together so it's
important to
make sure we specify two things one it's
really useful if several members of the
team from different disciplines are in
the same room working on the workbook
together because each guideline may have
implications not only for ui ux but also
for gene engineering and data science
um
it's also ideal the team was in the very
very early stages of developing this
feature and this is a great point
where you could stop and plan um for
implementing the guidelines for human ai
interaction
so let me show you their example as an
example their responses in the worksheet
for guideline two make clear how well
the system can do what it can do
and so this guideline is about letting
users know that the system is not
perfect and it might make mistakes
the team deemed this guideline as
relevant to the flagged search feature
and they thought that
applying this guideline might benefit a
user by making sure they don't blindly
trust the insights
and so if they see a flagged search they
would think and research and be careful
about taking actions like talking to
their children based on that
also in terms of not applying this
guideline it might harm a user because
parents could over rely on the future
could miss some unflagged searches and
or decide to take extreme measures
taking impact into consideration both
for applying and not applying the
guideline the team estimated that the
impact on the user for this particular
guideline would be high
moving on to the next step in the
workbook the team had to describe
requirements of how they might implement
it and this should include ui ai data
and engineering and in this case the
team decided that showing a message
to communicate that user that the app
the feature might not always be accurate
is uh the way to go and they estimated
the resource commitment for this
implementation as small
taking all of these decisions into
consideration the team prioritized
guideline 2 as a p0 meaning that they
would not ship the feature without this
being implemented
and so when we think about how we would
implement a guideline
we can go back to the hacks toolkit and
look at the hacks design library for
ideas the hacks design library includes
design patterns for some of the
guidelines that outline established
solutions to common ai problems it also
includes concrete examples from real
products and of course what's very
exciting for us is that anybody can
contribute new patterns and examples
and so let's try to take a look and see
how might a team implement a guideline
and how might they use the hacks design
library for help so i'm going to switch
over to the website and take a look at
guidelines one and two which were both
considered p0 for the team
so here we are on the hacks toolkit
website
and since we are interested in ideas for
implementing the guidelines we are going
to hop on to the hacks design library
in the hacks design library as i
mentioned before we have patterns and
examples for the guidelines in this case
we're going to narrow it down because
we're interested in guidelines one and
two since they were related and both of
them were considered p0 by the team
and we are also going to narrow it down
to just patterns that will give us some
ideas for how we could go about
implementing those guidelines
so if we take a look we can see
immediately a pattern that looks
interesting which is writing an
introductory blurb and if we keep
scrolling we could see other patterns
for how we could make clear what the
system can do guideline one
and also some patterns for implementing
guideline two
for example this one where we use
precision
in our communication in language and try
to match it with the system performance
so we're going to take a very quick look
at this pattern we can see that each
pattern has a problem solution when to
use how to use
common pitfalls and more and here we
could see that
one way in which we could communicate
that the system may make mistakes is
through intentional use of uncertainty
in language
we can also look at some examples of how
this pattern has been implemented in
other systems
and so for example we could see here one
screenshot from linkedin
where
it sets expectations for how well the
system can do what it can do by using
tentative language such as recommending
people you may know
okay so now we have a couple of
interesting candidate patterns let's go
back and see
how the team implemented guidelines one
and two as well as the other guidelines
that they selected as high priority so
if you remember there are 18 guidelines
the team answered the same questions in
the workbook for all the guidelines that
they
deemed as relevant to begin with and by
the end of the workbook they had decided
that these guidelines were high priority
for for the future so let's take a look
at what they did and how they ended
implementing these guidelines
the first thing that the team did to
implement guidelines one and two
they decided to use a pattern the
pattern that i showed the introductory
blurb pattern
and combine it with and also use it to
make clear how well the system can do
what it can do
they included a carousel style tutorial
for search activity and we're going to
try to go through it in the first tab
they explained uh what the feature does
and how it flags potentially concerning
search terms and note here the cautious
language potentially concerning search
terms it also delimited what the
system can do by saying it works with
search engines like bing or google
in microsoft edge and only in the
english language
in the second screen of the carousel it
shows further information about search
terms
explaining that search terms can fall
into a number of categories um and this
way they will be flagged
if they are for example in categories
like adult cyber bullying hate speech
violence
mental health
in the third tap of the carousel
the system introduces the lookup feature
which i will address a little bit
later it is also a way of implementing
guideline 11 make clear why the system
did what it did
and this shows that a parent can learn
more about a search term if they don't
immediately understand why it might have
been flagged now as you know those of
you who are parents sometimes it is
hard to understand the language and the
terms that um you know children or
tweens or teenagers use and so this
lookup feature can help clarify things
and finally in the last carousel they
also implemented guidelines 15 encourage
granular feedback and 16 convey the
consequences of user actions by
reminding users that they can um
let them know how they're doing once
again you see here the use of humble
language we're still learning and
sometimes we don't get it right tap on
an item to teach us if it should be
flagged or not and help us improve this
feature
so i'm going to also show a little bit
of information about what they did with
some of the other guidelines such as
guidelines six mitigate social biases
and so for this guideline um a lot of
time we spent a lot of time thinking
about what language to use and we
decided even though the team had been
using the word toxic that that could be
too strong and problematic um
in in certain situations and so we
narrowed it down and decided to just use
flagged the team did some work to reduce
some biases in the data set and their
models and after lengthy and a very
interesting and heartfelt discussion we
decided to exclude terms related to
sexuality we imagined a scenario in
which um a child might explore their own
sexuality and maybe wanted privacy from
their parents or maybe the parents would
be more
you know not very open minded and so we
decided that that should not those kind
of searches should not be flagged at all
in order to protect the child and
they're
discovering their own identity
guidelines 10 scope services when in
doubt this deals with how the system
deals with its own uncertainty when it's
not really sure about the user's goals
and guideline 11 made clear why the
system did what it did which were also
high priority to address these
guidelines um the team added certainty
thresholds and calibrated them so that
flagged
search
items would be shown when the certainty
was high
they also added screens to explain
uncertainty
and added this lookup feature right so
if a term is flagged
and a parent might not understand why it
is flagged there is this explanation we
flagged it because we think it's the
search falls under one or more of the
categories that i mentioned before but
if that explanation is not sufficient
then the parent has the option to look
up that term in order to
try to figure out what it means and
whether it is in indeed a reason for
concern or not
and of course you could see on the right
hand side
there's a
way to
provide feedback we're going to look at
it here closer a parent can tap on an
item and
can indicate
whether this item should or should not
be flagged which is uh implementation of
the guideline of guideline 15.
then the system
learns from this user behavior and it
communicates to the user that indeed
it's learning by applying guideline 16
convey the consequences of user actions
and showing a message
about what how the feedback will be used
now
let's think a little bit about the hacks
playbook the hacks playbook was not
available at the time when the team was
developing this feature however we can
take a look and see how the team could
have used the hacks playbook
to improve the user experience so i'm
going to switch over and show you the
hacks playbook really quickly
i am back at the hacks toolkit website
and i'm going to click on the hacks
playbook then
launch it and answer the questions in
the hacks playbook from the perspective
of this feature
now this system is a classification
system right flag or don't flag a search
the primary input modality is text and
it's very clear when it should
trigger and how it's delimited there
could be multiple valid interpretations
of the user's input as we saw with the
example with wheat weed killer and then
the
classification is of course binary and
you see as i check these boxes on the
left-hand side i get on the right-hand
side a number of scenarios that i could
look at and plan for knowing that these
might be possible errors now spelling
errors resulting in wrong input might
not be of the highest concern in this
case but if we look at response
generation errors right we see that um
there could be ambiguity and fortunately
the lookup feature deals with this and
we see that false negatives and false
positives could also be of concern and
so these would be scenarios for the team
to think about to anticipate that the
system is likely to produce these errors
um and prototype test and make sure they
account for these errors in the
application
so now that we've seen really quickly
how we could use the hacks playbook i'm
going to turn back and look at the
application for another second and
continue the presentation so coming back
to the app the microsoft family safety
app was launched it is now available uh
the flagged search feature is live
and the team told us that they really
benefited from using the hacks workbook
and they really enjoyed it too in fact
the data science manager of the team
told us that they've integrated the
workbook into their ai processes and
they're going to continue using it for
any other features that they'll be
working on in the future
and so we also have a little bit more
feedback from teams who have used the
hacks toolkit
they have found it as a team alignment
tool that puts everybody on the same
page and we know how important this is
as creating responsible and
human-centered ai requires deep
engagement and collaboration across
disciplines which tends to be very
difficult
the hacks toolkit helped people find
lots of points that they maybe would not
have considered before
um it gives people an opportunity to
build a much better product in gen 1 so
it shows that taking a little bit of
planning ahead of time
and a little bit of time to work through
the workbook for example it can really
save time in the long run
and create a much better product
the playbook can standardize the error
case design
and the guidelines serve as research
evidence for design decisions
and so we were very happy to hear this
from teams but we would also like to
hear from you just as a reminder these
are the four tools that are in the
hackstool toolkit right now
but um
we are hoping to
bring up more and we are hoping to keep
contributing to microsoft's holistic
approach to responsible ai which
includes not only principles but also
tangible tools and practices for data
science and engineering but also for ux
design user research and pm
in fact we have a web page with
responsibility resources that i
encourage you to visit and you will also
find there a research collection of
research papers published by microsoft
on the topic of responsible ai
but speaking of you
contributing we invite you to use the
hacks toolkit when you are working on
user facing ai
teach it if you are a faculty member
we encourage you to submit examples and
patterns to the design library and of
course to engage in research that
extends these tools to new scenarios or
contexts as well as building more tools
for
parts of the design process that maybe
we haven't yet addressed
we are very much looking forward to
hearing from you and working with you
and you can use the email address
hackstoolkit at microsoft.com to contact
salima and me
thank you so much and we look forward to
hearing from you